أنت تشاهد المحاولة
اليائسة لإنقاذ حياة مريض مصاب بالفيروس ،
هذه المرأة البالغة من العمر 75 عامًا تعاني من صعوبة خطيرة في
التنفس وهي في
حاجة ماسة إلى الأكسجين ، لذلك تم
الحفاظ على هذا المريض على التهوية غير الغازية
أه
ولسوء الحظ
فشلنا لذلك
اضطررنا إلى الانتقال  إلى
التهوية الميكانيكية التي تتطلب وضع
مجرى هوائي داخل القصبة الهوائية داخل
القصبة الهوائية ،
بحيث يتم تخدير المريض
للسماح لنا
بالوصول إلى مجرى الهواء ، دكتور هودمان هو
طبيب أمراض الرئة والمدير الطبي لوحدة العناية المركزة
في مستشفى سانت أنتوني
في  سانت بطرسبرغ فلوريدا مع
انخفاض مستويات الأكسجين لدى المريض ،
استعد الأطباء بسرعة لتنبيبها حتى يتمكنوا من
وضعها على جهاز التنفس الصناعي لمساعدتها
على التنفس ، تتضمن العملية
مسبارًا جراحيًا رفيعًا يُعرف باسم
النمط الذي يستخدمه لديه نمط
يدخل في الأنبوب إلى  يحافظ على بعض
الصلابة حتى يتمكن من توجيه المكان الذي
يذهب إليه الأنبوب ويستخدم شفرة منظار الحنجرة
لرفع اللسان من  حتى يتمكن من
تخيله وهو في الواقع تصور للألياف
الضوئية ،
توجد كاميرا صغيرة
في نهاية شفرة منظار الحنجرة حتى
تتمكن من تصور مجرى الهواء
وتوجيه الأنبوب في مكانه ، يجب أن يكون
دقيقًا ولكن الوقت هو جوهر الحياة
على المحك
[موسيقى]
لهذه المريضة فرصة ثانية
علمنا لاحقًا أنها تلقت
جرعتها الأولى من اللقاح ولكن
تمت تغطيتها أثناء انتظار اللقطة الثانية ،
لا يزال معظم المرضى هنا
غير محصنين عبر نظام مستشفى باي كير
الذي يتضمن مستشفى القديس
أنتوني  ازداد عدد حالات دخول المستشفى
عشرة أضعاف منذ بداية شهر
يوليو ، وحوالي 85 بالمائة من مرضى وحدة العناية المركزة
لم يتم تلقيحهم ، هل يعبرون عن أسفهم لعدم
تلقيحهم ، لدينا مرضى
يأتون ويطلبون
مثل هل يمكنني الحصول على لقاح الآن
لكنهم لا يفهمون
أنه شيء يُقصد منه أن يكون
وقائيًا وبمجرد إصابتك
بالمرض ، لن يكون مفيدًا
دكتور وارين أبيل طبيب الرعاية الحرجة في مكالمات وحدة العناية المركزة
يقتبس الوباء من
حربنا العالمية الثانية
المرضى غير المحصنين الذين لا تزيد أعمارهم عن 20
عامًا يموتون أمام عينيه ، كل
شخص يموت ولم يتم
تطعيمه ، إنه موت يمكن الوقاية
منه ، إنه أمر مفجع للغاية في
الواقع
27 من 28 سريرًا في
وحدة العناية المركزة هنا مليئة بالفيروس  مرضى صباح الخير
والكثير منهم يستخدمون أجهزة التنفس الصناعي مثل
هذه المرأة ، هل يمكنك أن تهز رأسك لي
هناك ، فأنت على ما يرام
دائمًا تقريبًا قبل أن يتم تنبيبها ،
يريدون الاتصال بأحبائهم
لإخبارهم أنهم يحبونهم ويقولون وداعًا
و  لسوء الحظ في كثير من الأحيان كانت هذه هي
المرة الأخيرة التي يتحدثون فيها إليهم ، أمشي
في القاعة وكان
جميع مرضانا تقريبًا على
بطونهم لمساعدتهم على
التنفس ، أخبرني المستشفى أنهم غمروا
في إمداداتهم من الإعصار من
أجهزة التنفس التي عادة ما يحتفظون بها
جانبًا للعواصف  يستخدمون أيضًا
هذه الوحدات المتنقلة المبردة
للمشارح وهناك أيضًا منازل جنازات في
المنطقة تشعر بالتأثير الذي
تحدثنا عنه  إلى مدير
الجنازة في منزل جنازة ويلسون وأخبرني أنه لم
يدفن أصدقاءه فحسب ، بل نفد أيضًا
من الصناديق ، وهو يطلب الآن
عدة صناديق كل يوم
ويجد صعوبة حتى في تحديد موعد
الجنازات لأن المقابر مكتظة جدًا
بحجز
راندي كاي  CNN تامبا